hey guys i'm jasmine and today riya is
going to teach me how to make one of her
favorite foods she ate growing up but
here is a couch
do you know any japanese word one word
right before i eat and it's itadakimasu
oh yes yes oh you speak well oh wow
thank you i can come to ten okay
okay
pronunciation is so good really yeah
well part of my family is japanese are
you my other side is half tony's half
japanese i'm half japanese korean i was
going to give you lifelines but i think
this tissue is super easy and you speak
fluent in germany
[Laughter]
she knows she knows
what's the what's the point of doing
this
there's japanese and mandarin that
overlap really yeah
it's prepared
since you're so good
i'm not i counted to ten and then they
took away my lifeline
and we added more ingredients are you
ready ready okay
bowl yes
how big two grain in a bowl okay
a medium-sized bowl i presume
i don't know
see like basically you understand well i
don't i don't i'm just guessing me
tamago egg see
it's because i like to eat japanese so
the food part okay tamago nico meat two
two eggs
[Music]
uh crack the eggs into the bowl
dashi
300 milliliters
yes
i don't know what's happening
[Music]
two tablespoons of mirin cheese sauce
teaspoon two teaspoon
milk
jatsugi meat sake
[Laughter]
you
put
maybe a little too much too much sake
this does not like you
we'll see maybe this is a make a better
recipe exactly yeah yes okay great thank
you very much very much
show you soy sauce show you um oh
show you show you show you hi show you
all
is
[Music]
[Laughter]
chopsticks
have you cooked japanese food before oh
yeah i cook a lot of japanese food but i
don't like cooking japanese in my head
i'll just be like i'm adding an egg you
know
christmas
christmas
i don't know
put it to the side check out oh strain
it
yummy sweet torii
i need a cutting board
so when you have cutting board what else
do you need a knife
are you scared
chicken
is
wash my hands first and then we're going
to do them
wow there's even soap in there i thought
it was a fake soap dispenser
i usually wash my mushrooms that's
do you always exit like that yes
remove the stems
really actually
but i think there's only few things you
can do so but you're right you're like
i'm not actually that impressed
that's so easy
but you see the kids the stem i usually
just peel it off okay yeah you do you oh
i love it freedom
one just one oh i did three you do you
do i cut it thin slices
even before i even say like
please i'm just guessing do you know
what i'm making today no i have no clue
just thin slice hoffman
i don't even know what this is in
english
ceramic plate um
this one with four chickens
mushrooms just a couple pieces
a little like pizza pouring thingy
follow your heart follow my heart how do
you say that in japanese
that's hard it's more like uh follow
your first instinct yeah instinct
i know what it is
katie not
i can hear it why don't we hide it how
do we hold it
you're saying that how do we hold it
do you want to go look around
me i'm crying
[Laughter]
i did not hear that
i did not hear them
i like hot pot and then the original
flavor is mizu or did you know flavor
yeah it's like original like no flavor
oh like it's tacky
yeah that's right
so you learn a lot of japanese by going
to restaurants oh yeah paper towel
going to put a paper towel in the pan
put the little round bowls on the paper
towel
and then water hi it's
halfway full um
okay
[Laughter]
so we're going to put this to the side
and let it cook
you know we need a second hot plate what
are we doing
oh more water
i heard
[Laughter]
wow you remember i'm remembering hi kino
sayo snappy hi sujiyo torimas we're
going to slice it we're going to strip
this hi
yes that's good my mom always tells me
to be more gentle
i
a little bit of rice vinegar check on
our eggs so
[Music]
lower the heat high to medium heat
oh ten
five one five fifteen minutes yes yes
yes yes
i forgot
oh snap peas
oh we're going to make them crunchy here
okay so we could take them out hi
take it out
i know if you put in a food too long in
ice water it causes ice
water clogged
so you should not
leave it too long too long
maybe
shrimp
shrimp tempura is heavy tempura evil
put it in the water
hi how many
ichi neet too
uh we're gonna take it out real quick
once it's cooked
oh when it's pink
we're gonna take it out
abio koori mizuni
korimizu put in ice water
toridashima take it out
[Music]
peel the shrimp
leave
yes
put it to
oh we're gonna check on our eggs yes
okay
there's one oh oh it's kind of sad
i think it's a little loose let's see
you out of so much sucker no
i did not right
oh it smells good it smells amazing must
be all that sake that i added
oh beautiful
what tonight is
a bee heavy shrimp no
do i have to cut it
so i just place it on top
it's set enough to like be placed on top
jatsuki uh snow peas
put it beautifully
oh nice i like that
oh caviar oh caviar it's not caviar it's
a salmon raw
salmon salmon row just a little bit on
top wow this is beautiful
yeah it kind of pops the color right
yeah
so i'm going to get mine and we can
compare yours and mine okay here it is
i'm excited
[Music]
you look great i think you added too
much sake so it jiggles
but it's brothy
yes
and it looks delicious oh my god you're
so nice she's like covering up my big
big mess up do you know why it's this
it's called chawa mushi have you had
anything similar before yes i make
keranjin which is like korean steamed
egg it's a similar process but i don't
put too much love and carrots and when i
make it i kind of just throw it together
mix it all up and then steam it oh yeah
i know which one you're talking about
yeah the one when you go to korean
restaurants yeah i thought it was tofu
because it's so fluffy it's like so
silky right
it's so good i can't wait you to try
this should we try mine first yes i hope
you like it yeah it looks great
[Music]
so soft don't even need to chew it
doesn't taste like sake it doesn't it
tastes like dashi broth and mushrooms
delicious sugar
good job
thank you all right let's try mine okay
still jiggly wow
this really looks like tofu
[Music]
oh yeah yours tastes different yours is
like a little sweeter i feel like this
tastes actually better really maybe i
should bulk up sake
well thank you so much for teaching me
this
thank you
it's so delicious it's so good next time
it's my turn
okay thank you so much for watching bye
oh yes
you